a crackdown on dangerous drivers more  than a dozen arrests across the valley  street racing the focus of a specialized  team within metro it's called raid and  their task stop the lingering trend of  drifting and racing on our roads  sunday night raid detectives tell us  they arrested 21 people that includes  drivers as spectators as well  13 cars and five guns were taken it all  happened near apex northeast of town  i don't know what's going on i go out to  the to the intersection and the cars are  just doing donuts smoke everywhere  fireworks kids in the street sitting on  the car  super dangerous  metro reports a 71 percent spike this  year at excessive speed in deadly  crashes if you have any tips about  street racing reckless driving you are  urged to email metro  raid  lvmpd.com  for